so when somebody finds you attractive  what you will find is a itch at the back  of their hand very lightly like this or  scratch their collarbone so if you're  talking to somebody and they start doing  this around you it's because they find  you attractive okay we finally hear from  a man that's the good news bad news is  that he's full of crap  um if someone finds you attractive  they'll itch their hand if someone is  itching themselves in your presence  they're either madly in love with you or  they have a skin condition I mean what  if somebody hears this takes it into  heart and then um they see someone  scratching their hands at like  Thanksgiving dinner with their family  you're gonna end up making some really  horrible and unfair assumptions about  your grandmother